bon la technique est au point à kurou
même si parfois il y a quelques retard
le lanceur européen vous le savez on
vous l'a dit est fiable et les clients
étrangers le savent le pas de tir est
donc libre à kil tour et là surprise ça
sera la fusée lunaire de Tintin qui
prendra le départ lancement prévu le 21
juillet prochain jour anniversaire du
premier pas de l'homme sur la lune et
oui c'était il y a 20 ans le compte
Harbour a commencé Patrick tournesol non
Esther ces images ont été volées par une
caméra a caché d'Antenne 2 elles
permettent d'affirmer que les travaux
menés dans le plus grand secret sur la
fusée lunaire du professeur tournosol
ont abouti bien sûr le moteur atomique
n'est pas encore au point et pour le
premier vol on utilisera un classique
moteur à poudre et oui RG a encore
quelques années d'avance sur les
techniciens ce n'est pas Tintin qui me
détrompera le copit de la fusée adamier
vaut encore largement celui de la
navette américaine quant au plan ils
soutiennent allègrement la comparaison
avec ceux de la Saturne 5 d'Apollo 11 il
ne faudrait quand même pas oublier que
le capitaine hadoc avait débarqué sur la
lune 20 ans avant Armstrong et Aldrin
mais aujourd'hui c'est bien connu on ne
croit plus en rien et certains ont
éprouvé le besoin de vérifier quelques
détails techniques j'ai eu la chance de
connaître RG et j'ai fait une étude sur
ce qu'il avait
imaginé en 1949 et les tirs àollo et un
jour j'ai rencontré Monsieur van V du
centre spatial et je lui ai mis cette
idée dans la tête alors c'est une fusée
sérieuse ben c'est une fusée des plus
sérieuses puisqu'il s'agit d'une fusée
d'un club club de courou qui doit être
lancé le 21 juillet sur le centre social
guillanais et le cè pour l'occasion
fournit le propulseur et toutes les
conditions de sécurité d'un lancement
professionnel alors bon voyage du pont
et du pont mais faites quand même
attention en montant les escaliers il ne
faudrait pas briser l'engin avant le
décollage